bonjour à tous alors je suis vraiment
super heureuse d'être avec vous cet
après midi donc d'autant que moi est en
fête jehan vous raconter le plus beau
jour de ma vie en fait c'était plutôt le
plus beau jour de la vie de la jeune
fille que j'étais à l'époque pourtant
c'était vraiment pas du tout une journée
qui qui commençait très bien le temps
était exécrable il y avait du brouillard
il y avait de la bruine y avait du
crachin tout ça et là mon père me dit
tiens me dis à mes deux frères et moi
nous dit tiens ça vous dit pas de venir
faire un tour en bateau
alors là franchement on adore le bateau
mais avec le temps qui faisait on
n'était vraiment pas du tout motivé et
pourtant bon les parents savent bien
faire ça de temps en temps ils ont
réussi à nous convaincre
il a réussi et du coup nous voilà donc
sur sur le zodiac dans la dans le
brouillard
et puis donc on distingue donc on a nos
gros écart when our gros manteau et on
distingue au loin un autre
zodiac en fait et donc on s'en rapproche
un petit peu et à ce moment là en fait
on voit comme des formes noires en fait
qui nagent autour de autour du zodiaque
alors au début j'ai pensé à des
plongeurs je ne sais pas du tout
pourquoi est en fait plus on se
rapprochait de deux seules autres zodiac
en fait un moment ses formes noires sont
arrivés vers nous nous aurons vraiment
foncer dessus et là à ce moment là en
fait je me suis rendu compte que c'était
des dauphins et c'était pas des dizaines
de dauphins
c'était des centaines de dauphins et à
ce moment là je me souviens je me suis
mis à l'avant du zodiaque et j'étais
plus tendu comme ça je tendais lebrun et
je sais de les toucher et je sais plus
si j'ai dit à mon père aussi je les
pensais très fort mais je me suis dit
que c'était vraiment le plus beau jour
de toute ma vie et à partir de ce moment
là je pense pouvoir dire que les
dauphins n'ont plus jamais quitté et
peut-être ça a participé à mon amour
justement du comportement des animaux
sauvages et donc c'est assez logiquement
qu'en fait à 19h décide de devenir
éthologue donc spécialiste du
comportement des animaux sauvages et
donc bon bah je m'avance vers la licence
master le parcours assez classique mais
en fait ça ne se passera pas exactement
comme ça puisque j'ai quand même essayé
j'ai commencé
licence j'ai tenu deux semaines et parce
que bon bah la théorie en fait on
passait notre temps depuis le collège le
lycée être dans la théorie et là je
crois que j'avais c'était plus possible
ce têt et du coup je me suis dit bon ben
maintenant il faut que je me mette à
pratiquer en fait c'est ça qui me fait
c'est ça qui me donne envie
donc quoi de mieux pour pratiquer que de
partir directement sur le terrain et là
je décide du coup de partir au canada ce
que le canada moi j'en rêvais depuis
super longtemps les grands espaces le
sirop d'érable
les orignaux tout ça et puis en fait la
vie on a un petit peu décidé autrement
puisque en fait le destin m'a amené en
israël donc vous voyez il n'y a pas
grand chose à voir et surtout que je
suis parti du coup étudier les vautours
dans les montagnes du golan donc me
voilà rendus en israël et tous les
matins alors je pars avec mon sac à dos
ma longue vue et je pars toute la
journée comme ça et je vais étudier les
vautours dans les falaises et donc petit
à petit je me familiarise avec leur
comportement
après des heures d'observation un jour
je fais une observation vraiment étrange
en fait j observe un adulte qui est en
train de qui à côté de quoi à côté de
son nid et qui est en train d'essayer de
relever son adhésion est en fait donc
très très très délicatement avec son bec
il passe son mec en dessous la tête de
son aux ions et je vois la tête de
l'oisillon qui retombe
je réalise qu'en fait son adhésion est
mort et donc je vais observer encore ce
manège pendant un moment et le lendemain
quand je vais revenir
en fait je trouve ce vautour là debout à
côté du nid
le regard dans le vide est vraiment
c'était un comportement très étrange
pour moi
l'oisillon était toujours dans le nid
mort et c'est seulement troisième jour
quand je vais revenir qu'à ce moment là
en fait je vais voir le vautour commencé
à prendre son envol a commencé à faire
des petits cercles comme ça est de plus
en plus grands et jusqu'au moment où le
vautour va partir et moi j'ai vraiment
vécu ça vraiment comme en fait le deuil
en fait je venais d'observer d'après moi
2 un deuil chez un vautour donc je ne
pensais pas jusqu'à ce moment là en fait
que je pensais bien que le deuil
existait chez les animaux mais je
l'avais jamais observé de mes yeux et du
coup ça m'a vraiment interrogé du coup
sûr le propre de l'homme là je me suis
dit bon bah alors j'ai commencé à
fouiller un peu c'est quoi le propre de
l'homme donc le propre de l'homme c'est
un peu le comportement qu'on cherche
pour se dire que l'homme est
complètement différent des autres
d autres animaux et donc on a beaucoup
cherché on a commencé très tôt il ya un
monsieur qui s'appelle un axe agge or je
crois qui a dit en fait ce qui sépare
l'humain des des autres animaux c'est le
fait qu'ils ont des mains alors cet
homme là devait pas voyagé beaucoup mais
est on pour sa décharge c'était il ya
très très longtemps
et puis après il ya d'autres personnes
qui devaient pas voyagé beaucoup non
plus qu'ils ont dit bon bah c'est que
nous on a un plus gros cerveau et puis
après quelqu'un d'autre a dit mais nous
on utilise des outils
donc à chaque fois on se rendait compte
qu'en fait c'était pas vrai mais il ya
quand même une que j'aime et que j'ai
quand même particulièrement apprécié on
s'est rendu compte que certains animaux
utilisaient des outils et y en a il ya
un petit malin à katyn ouais mais nous
on réutilise des outils lui j'ai
beaucoup aimé quand même est la même là
pas de bol en fait certains animaux
réutilise eux aussi des outils donc à
partir de ce moment là faut savoir que
le débat est encore en cours on cherche
toujours
et puis il ya quelque chose que j'ai
appris aussi entre temps peut-être vous
le savez déjà mais c'est qu'on partage
40% de notre adn avec le ver de terre
ça doit représenter à peu près ça 40% de
l'adn avec le ver de terre donc l'adn
c'est un peu comme le mode d'emploi des
organismes on va dire donc on partage
40% de notre mode d'emploi avec le ver
de terre 60% avec la poule 80% avec les
souris 95% avec le port et 99,4 % avec
le chimpanzé
donc ça fait réfléchir un peu et les
chimpanzés j'ai eu la chance de les
rencontrer en afrique de l'ouest et de
travailler un petit peu avec eux est en
fait un moment j'ai étudié deux adultes
en brousse deux mâles adultes et donc
pour aller les voir tous les jours je
traversais comme une rivière un petit
bras de fleuve à la nage et puis
j'arrive de l'autre côté et donc je les
avait appelés les chimpanzés étaient là
les deux mâles étaient là tout se
passait très bien et un moment je vois
un des deux mâles mais s'énerver se met
en position d'agression il devait être à
20-25 mètres de moi donc c'est à dire
que bon il se met debout sur ses deux
jambes qui commence à se balancer comme
ça d'une jambe sur l'autre
on appelle ça un display dont qui ce
même faire un display en moi j'étais en
position de soumission comme on fait
toujours avec les chimpanzés adultes on
est toujours un petit peu comme ça non
non c'est toi le plus fort voilà j'ai
forcément envie de me confronter en tout
cas là lui il avait envie de se
confronter et puis donc moi j'étais là
je le vois c'est bouriffé semaine debout
et s'est énervé c'est bouriffé c'est à
dire que ces poils se dresse donc il a
l'air de faire encore d'être encore
trois fois plus gros et puis il se prend
avril prend une branche et puis il se
met à taper sur le sol comme ça et puis
alors du coup il se met un moment à me
charger et moi j'étais par terre comme
ça et je n'avais pas le temps de courir
jusqu'au fleuve j'avais pas enfin voila
je n'étais pas et là donc il me charge
donc il ya 20 m 15 m dit m 5 m
et là j'ai une réaction complètement
inattendu on va dire en fait au lieu de
me protéger lui ouvre les bras et je
l'accueille et jeudi au wahoo je suis
tellement contente de voir moi il a dû
sentir que j'étais pas non plus très
très très fier j'avais la voie qu'ils
aient plutôt comme ça mais n'empêche que
ça vraiment il s'est passé quelque chose
de très très fort à ce moment là c'est
que moi je m'attendais à ce moment là
donc j'ai complètement lâché prise et
j'ai complètement ouvert à dire bah
advienne que pourra
et en fait à ce moment là donc je
m'attendais vraiment à recevoir un choc
une morsure ou pire
les championnats sont très agressifs
peuvent être très très violent et en
fait à ce moment là le fait d'avoir
ouvert les bras
ça a tout changé sellal comme
décontenancé et s'est assis devant moi
et il s'est mis à me fouiller en signe
d'apaisement social est alors moi là ça
m'a surpris tellement surpris je me suis
dit waouh
on remet alors si j'ai le pouvoir
simplement avec mon positionnement
simplement lâchant prise en étant dans
le présent et en ouvrant en accueillant
au lieu de me renfermer en lieu de me
protéger au lieu de fuir si je peut
désamorcer une charge d'un champ pas et
adultes peut-être que ça je peux le
faire dans toute ma vie est alors du
coup la vie m'a amené je vais raconter
ça rapidement un allez pouvoir l'exercer
chez moi parce que je suis revenu et
puis j'étais un moment caissière dans un
magasin est là du coup j'ai vu un peu
tout de suite cette scène là mes revenus
j'ai vu une dame qui arrivent et qui
avait l'air très en colère je
l'entendais déjà je l'entendais déjà
grogner un peu et puis moi je me suis
dit bon ça y est ça c'est pour moi je
vais prendre toute la frustration tout
ça et puis en caisse c'est comme dans la
brousse à on peut pas vraiment fuir et
où un joker donc elle arrive elle arrive
vers moi comme ça et puis là je me dis
ouais ok je j'ai pensé aux gros champ
pas et je me suis dit hé ben c'est
pareil ouvre accueille là et tu vas voir
ce que voilà peut-être ça va changer
quelque chose dans tout cas je sais
coûtait rien de tester et c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait elle est
arrivée je fais mon plus grand sourire
j'ai et je lui ai dit bonjour j'ai
demandé comment elle allait tout ça et
ça a fonctionné
en fait elle s'est complètement son
visage s'est détendu et on a même pu
blague est un petit peu et on a passé
toutes les deux un très bon un très bon
moment donc je me suis dit que vraiment
tout ce que ce que j'avais appris la saa
et et c'était le début vraiment d'une
grande prise de conscience pour moi ce
sujet là et puis j'ai pris une autre
leçon
alors cette fois c'était très loin de la
brousse puis c'était sur un petit îlot
volcanique qui est située dans l'océan
indien je sais pas ça
en connaissent ça s'appelle l'île
d'amsterdam donc c'est un tout petit il
est en fait donc elle est très éloignée
des autres continents c'est même là
l'île la plus isolée du monde
en réalité et donc c'est à trois
semaines de bateaux à partir de l'île de
la réunion
là bas j'ai étudié une colonie d'otaries
à fourrure donc les otaries à fourrure
en fait c'est pas vraiment celle qu'on
voit dans les eaux
moi aussi au début je croyais mais quand
je suis arrivé là bas j'ai vite compris
que c'était pas ça du tout et en fait
les otaries surtout la sur 7 sur une
zone de reproduction en fait sont très
agressive donc le mal il a six à huit
femelles dans son arrêt mais il les
protège très très agressivement on va
dire donc on se faisait chargé tout le
temps en fait parler par les mâles et
par les femelles qui essaient de deux
nous croquer quand on passait et donc ce
jour là en fait
ah oui il faut les voir les mâles aussi
où ils ont vraiment ils sont
particulières ils sont dressés sur leurs
pattes mur comme ça et puis ils font 200
kilos quand même c'est des belles voilà
c'était beau mâle et puis séparé la
pression mâchoire d'un ours
j'ai eu la chance de pas testé et puis
ils ont une petite houpette comme ça
comme une petite crête et puis donc
et quand il charge ils sont tellement
rapides qu'ils ont l'air de voler au
dessus des rochers pour venir nous
attaquer c'est super impressionnant et
donc ce jour là en fait je vois un de
ces mâles la très fier sur ses pas le
mur et je vois autour de son cou un une
corde en fait c'est il était cercle est
ce qu'on appelle cercle et c'est quand
ils se prennent dans un filet de pêche
est en fait il ya une partie qui reste
bloqué autour de leur cou et au fur et à
mesure qu'ils grossissent en fait ils
vont s'étrangler avec donc quand je vois
ce mal là ça m'est arrivé de trouver des
femelles et des jeunes cerclé de la même
manière que j'avais réussi à libérer
mais quand jamais j'avais trouvé dommage
je croisais les doigts pour que ça
n'arrive jamais et que je n'ai pas à le
libérer
et pourtant quand je les ai vus la
semelle de 200 kg avec son cerclage
jaune autour du cou à aucun moment j'ai
pensé que je n'allais pas le faire
c'était sûr et certain je pouvais y
laisser ma vie mais je voulais sauver
cette otaries et du coup c'est très
amusant parce qu'à partir du moment où
je me suis mis dans ce dans cette
présence où j'ai vraiment compris que
j'allais le faire peu importe ce qui se
passe c'est comme si vous
j'entendais plus de son tout était tout
était hyper clair dans ma tête donc
j'avais toujours ce bâton avec moi
j'avais pris le crochet le scotch dans
mon sac du coup j'ai je mets le scotch
autour du crochet et puis en fait donc
je m'approche je sais pas trop comment
parce que d'habitude donc il ya des
otaries sûr surtout loué rocher en fait
j'ai vraiment couru de rocher en rocher
comme ça jusqu'à lui est gelée près tout
de suite j'ai réussi à prendre le filet
derrière sa tête et a tiré dessus et en
fait est le mal a pas bougé alors que
d'habitude tout le temps je me faisais
chargé et là j'ai vraiment compris qu
encore une fois la force de mon
intention cette présence que j'avais eu
en fait avait réellement créer une bulle
en fait et c'est un peu cette moi
j'appelle ça un peu la bulle de présence
dans laquelle en fait quand on est dans
le moment présent quand on est en pleine
conscience
en fait c'est comme si tout était
possible
comme si vraiment il n'y avait plus
aucune plus aucun frein est en fait je
me suis rendu compte aussi que
mentalement du coup on était souvent
dans le passé souvent dans le futur donc
en fait on n'arrivait pas trop à vivre
dans ce moment présent l'un est donc
soit on est dans le passé où on ressasse
des choses soit on est dans le futur on
s'imagine des choses et donc en fait
vraiment d'être dans cette présence là
j'avais compris à quel point lui ça
avait transformé
aussi il avait plu il était resté là je
m'étais pas fait charger et ça ça a
vraiment été aussi une grande prise de
conscience pour moi donc la troisième
disons la troisième leçon ça a été
c'était en russie avec avec une louve
que j'étudiais donc j'avais pour mission
de
tester la performance des colliers gps
sur des loups est donc rapidement il
s'est créé une relation tellement
fusionnel entre nous que je pouvais lui
enlever les colliers et lui remettra la
main et j'ai jamais eu besoin de
l'endormir et donc quand j'arrivais vers
elle en fait j'ai enlevé mes raquettes
pour pas faire de bruit et pour profiter
du silence de la taïga et en jour je
suis tombé dans un trou de neige alors
que je la suivais et à ce moment là en
fait elle s'est retourné vers moi et on
s'est retrouvés vraiment les yeux à
exactement à la même hauteur
et là dans ma tête donc c'est le mental
qui a commencé à tourner un petit peu je
me suis moi en fait
à ce moment là maintenant je suis une
proie et mais j'ai pense j'ai pensé ça
en oubliant un peu la confiance que
j'avais en est là et la confiance
réciproque qu'on avait créé et en fait
j'ai j'étais complètement dans ma
vulnérabilité et j'ai accueilli vraiment
ce moment et j'ai vu qu'elle avait un
comportement et qui m'a paru assez
étrange au début donc elle partait de
elle partait et revenait elle partait
est revenue elle faisait 2 mètres est
revenu mais ea qui se mettait à pleurer
en fait comme si vraiment elle et elle
était gênée m débat vient qu'est ce que
tu fais et puis et puis à un moment elle
a fait quelque chose de kim est vraiment
resté et elle a essayé elle est revenue
elle a essayé de prendre une branche en
procédant et de l'amener vers man 1 et
là j'ai compris qu'elle essayait elle
avait compris que j'étais bloqué et
qu'elle essayait de que je puisse
m'exprimer en fait du trou et donc à ce
moment là le fait d'être dans cette
vulnérabilité en fait le fait de lâcher
prise complètement sur ce qui était en
train de se passer
j'ai pu vraiment vivre ce moment avec
elle et lâcher aussi toute cette
impression de contrôle et ça m'a
vraiment aussi appris ça en fait que
quand d'ouvrir à la vulnérabilité
ça peut ouvrir aussi un autre champ des
possibles et donc il y avait une image
que ma mère nous donnait par rapport au
lâcher prise et au contrôle c'était que
vous voyez elle nous parlait d'une
grande rivière en fait mais de rivière
très rapide avec
du courant tout ça et pied avec des
rochers et puis avec toi mais une grosse
rond au milieu de la rivière
c'est comme si on était tous accrochés
sur le tronc et qu'on avait beaucoup
trop peur de ce qu'il y avait derrière
et donc on était on était bien trop peur
de perdre le contrôle trop peur de
lâcher prise et en fait on est toujours
dans du coup on peut pas vraiment vivre
le moment présent on peut pas vraiment
vivre ce qui est en train de se passer
tant qu'on est justement dans ce
contrôle est en fait j'ai eu
l'impression lors de ces trois histoires
lors de ses trois années d'autres là
qu'en fait j'avais réussi à lâcher un
peu en fait ce gros tronc a lâché prise
à ouvrir à la vulnérabilité et ça avait
vraiment modifier mon positionnement nos
non seulement auprès des animaux
sauvages mais aussi dans ma vie de tous
les jours
et du coup ça va ça m'avait complètement
transformé du coup les animaux sauvages
m'ont beaucoup appris
à ce niveau là a pris par rapport à mon
positionnement mais j'ai aussi appris
évidemment beaucoup de choses de même
j'ai appris que les animaux pouvaient
manipuler pouvez tricher pouvait du p et
j'ai aussi appris des choses beaucoup
plus belle j'ai appris que en fait il
avait une intelligence émotionnelle pour
certains extraordinaire une grande
intelligence sociale et je me suis dit
que peut-être on pouvait s'inspirer de
pour certaines choses et que finalement
on est toujours un peu j'ai l'impression
c'est assez amusant et en même temps et
c'est triste on est toujours un peu
tourné vers l'extérieur on cherche des
extraterrestres quand des formes de vie
super intelligente tout ça alors que
j'ai l'impression que ces formes de
vilains très intelligente est différente
de nous sont déjà présentes sur sur
cette terre du coup finalement peut-être
que moi j'aimerais que mon rêve en fait
c'est que le propre de l'homme
peut-être que ça puisse d'être un peu
les gardiens les garants en fait de la
de la survie et du bien-être de tous les
êtres vivants humains et non humains
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]